hey guys my name is Jess McDonald today
it's the 14th of May and you're watching
games what news Konami have now switched
gears officially claiming that Mobile is
now their main platform Konami president
Hideki hayakawa told me okay as
translated by neo gap that the future of
gaming lies within mobile so that's
where they'll be he also highlighted
that the company will be invested in
free to play games and that they have a
keen interest in bringing more of their
popular series to mobile the ships to
mobile has been pretty significant for
the japanese market lately with nintendo
recently entering into a deal with
global mobile games publisher DNA to
help bring nintendo IP to smart devices
Deadly Premonition director hit attack
us a hero otherwise known as swear he
has revealed some new slightly solid in
details about his next game the dev of
xbox one and pc exclusive d for dark
dreams don't die described to some
elements of his next in development game
that aren't exactly pg-13 that's a high
school girl detective and her vivid
imagination and you're gonna have to dig
up the specifics in our story on
gamespot swear he says publishers
haven't been too keen on the idea
because it's to quote perverted in
things that a vague swear he also said
he's working on quote virtual reality
stuff finally Sony our way into no man's
sky pledging their support behind the
title as if it were first party no man's
sky is a timed exclusive for the ps4 and
it will come to PC later on no word yet
on whether it will make its way to Xbox
one sony UK managing director Fergal
gara said quote is it all comes together
as well as expected it will be treated
like a first-party release it's not a
self-published small indie title on the
platform Sony took a similar stance with
bungie's destiny and Gaara has suggested
that Sony may end up releasing a boxed
version of the game let me know down in
the comments if you think mobile is the
future of gaming or not and why
had the game spot where we've got
stories on the ps4 holiday lineup and
microsoft plans for e3 that it's all the
good stuff that i have for you today but
be sure to pop back tomorrow where i'll
have the top five best stories of the
whole gaming week I'll feed it